- It's always nice to finish up the hour
with something uplifting
and fun from social media.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
So it happened.
I found the Internet's most
unlikely celebrity news junkie,
71-year-old, retired Uncle Butch.
And it turns out
he's our associate producer,
Morgan's, real uncle,
and we have him on the line right now
watching on Fox 26 Houston at three.
What's up, Uncle Butch?
(audience applauding)
- Hey
- What's up Texas?
Well it's great to meet you.
So how did you get into
celebrity magazines?
- Well, I retired from
the aero craft industry
about 45 years,
and a guy at work
was bringing his girlfriend's
celebrity magazines to work,
and we'd read 'em on break.
But I'm not a fast reader
so I asked him could I bring them home?
Well, next time he brought 'em to work
he gave me a stack, and he just kept
on bringing and bringing them.
And I would bring them
home, and I'd read them
to the wee hours at night.
Some of my favorites was Brad Pitt.
I love Tom Cruise.
I love his new movie.
And then some of the
girls that I really like
is Jennifer Garner, she's a sweetheart.
And I just got into
reading the good people.
Sandra Bullock.
Reese Witherspoon.
I liked reading the nice
people in the magazines.
- I love that.
I love all those people.
I love how you view it too,
like with such positivity.
So like what do you love
about these magazines?
Is it that it is positive?
You love supporting all these,
these people that you find cool
or like pretty good humans?
- Well, when I get up in the morning
I turn on the news and
then I get, I'm sad.
Cause to me, all, anything
in the news is sad.
And then I go to my Hallmark
movies and that keeps me happy.
But then I relate that to my magazines.
When I read my magazines, I
read about all the good stuff.
I don't need to read about the bad people.
We got enough of them in the world.
But I enjoy reading my magazines
and trying to be happy.
- I love that Uncle Butch.
Oh my god, you wanna say
hi to your niece, Morgan?
She's right over there, just saying.
- Hey, Morgan.
- Hey Uncle Butch, love you.
- I am adopt, Morgan, I'm
adopting your Uncle Butch.
(laughs)
Uncle Butch, everybody.
(audience applauding)
We love you so much.
I'm liking your post right now.
That's not all though.
Our season long partner,
Pilot pen makers of FriXion,
the Go-To Erasable pen of
The Kelly Clarkson Show
want to celebrate
fearless people like you.
So they are giving you a thousand dollars
and you can use it for even
more magazine subscriptions.
(audience applauding)